[Music]
well the world rejoiced yesterday when
candy maker mars incorporated announced
that it would be rebranding m m's to
make them more inclusive and progressive
for the year 2022 as part of their quote
global commitment to creating a world
where everyone feels they belong and
society is inclusive
this is one of the final pieces
necessary to usher in an age of harmony
and tranquility now all we need is for
the patriarchal gender essentialist mike
and ikes and the violent and triggering
pop rocks to finally evolve as well
we are on the cusp of utopia
so close i can taste it
it tastes sweet and has 35 grams of
sugar per serving nobody expected that
civilization could be saved
by junk food brands
but they've been at the the front lines
in the battle against bigotry for a long
time actually it began two years ago
when gushers tweeted in support of blm
they tweeted gushers wouldn't be gushers
without the black community and your
voices we're working with fruit by the
foot on creating space to amplify that
we see you we stand with you
prior to this statement most people had
never thought about the intersectional
relationship between fruit snacks and
racial justice but the dream team of
fruit by the foot and gushers changed
all of that
junk food brands have been leading the
charge ever since and brands in general
have remained at the forefront in the
struggle for tolerance and equality we
talked yesterday about about audi's ad
promoting gender sensitive language
every day another brand steps up the
brands are our guiding light the brands
will show us the way the brands will
save us
or so we hope
but sadly
as i read more
about eminem's alleged efforts to
promote inclusion and diversity i found
myself unsatisfied
come to think of it we even need to ask
some questions about gushers
whatever happened to the space that it
was supposed to make to amplify black
voices that was two years ago
i have not heard any black voice
amplified by a fruit snack in the two
years since
i've seen black people buy fruit snacks
i've seen them eat for snacks i haven't
seen the fruit snack do anything for
them though
the fruit snack just sits there
passively waiting to be consumed
its silence is deafening it silences
violence
what about m ms well the vp of the
company appeared on the website cheddar
news where all important news is
reported to talk about the brand's
mission and vision for the year ahead
here she is explaining how eminem's she
hopes will spark a movement
and change the world
m ms is on a mission to create a world
where everyone feels they belong we're
wanting to start a movement to remind
everyone that despite our differences we
have an incredibly powerful thing in
common as a community which is the power
of fun
it's actually a reaffirmation a concrete
commitment to what we've always believed
as a brand
that the power of fun is the most
important way that we can help people
feel included and increase that sense of
belonging and as you mentioned as a
reflection of that you're going to see
our brand evolve in its look and feel to
reflect a dynamic and the dynamic and
progressive world that we're living in
sounds promising there's nothing lofty
about a brand of candy promising to
fundamentally change and reshape society
in fact historians agree that a great
number of the major revolutions in human
history have been sparked by different
types of candies the reese's revolution
of 1645 just one example but let's
listen to their to their actual plan
because here's where things go off the
rails a little bit i think
how will m m's be more inclusive exactly
listen
so as an iconic brand that's been around
for actually over 80 years it's really
important that we're evolving over time
as well and one of the most powerful
ways we can do that is through our
beloved characters you'll see them as
we've done a deep look at them both
inside as well as out
in terms of reflecting new looks
personalities and backstories for
example green you'll see her better
reflect empowerment and confidence and
be known for more than just her shoes
you're going to see green and brown
together being a supporting force for
women who are throwing shine and not
shade you'll also see orange really
embrace his true self worries and all
and not be afraid to express it we
actually know orange is the most
relatable of our characters in the crew
it's based on some conversations we've
had with gen z which we know is the most
anxious generation and beyond our
characters you'll see things such as our
increased
color palette as well as the different
sizes and shapes of our lentils and a
personal favorite of mine are more of an
emphasis on the ampersand it's a
distinctive element of the m m's logo
that connects the two m's together and
it's really a signal of our belief as a
brand that we are better together
wow
well there's no question that women
across the country will be uplifted and
empowered by the green and brown eminem
now the support of these two
anthropomorphized pieces of candy will
be crucial to women in fact not but a
week ago i came into the living room and
i found my wife collapsed on the couch
in tears i asked her what was wrong
and she told me that she didn't feel
supported by the green eminem and all i
could do was hold her and weep with her
now m m's have addressed this problem
and that is
admirable and important
and there's likewise no doubt that we
all will derive inspiration from the
orange m m as he embraces his true self
it's always been clear to me that the
orange eminem was repressing his true
identity hiding his truth away in fear
and it brings me comfort to know that
he'll finally be able to live
authentically but with all that said
eminems have still dropped the ball
significantly
first of all it is unconscionable that
in the year 2022 there still is no overt
lgbt representation in the eminem
community
perhaps the true self stuff is supposed
to hint at the orange m m sexuality but
but mere hinting is not even close to
good enough
we have to know in very precise terms
about the orange m m's sexual identity
and gender expression is he gay is he
bisexual is he a trans eminem is he a
genderqueer non-binary transmasculine
two-spirit demisexual the fact that he's
still forced to keep this part of
himself locked away only shows that m
m's as a company
is not serious in its commitment to
diversity and inclusion
indeed its erasure of lgbt identities is
a direct assault on an already
marginalized community which has been
waiting too long for candy brand
representation
further while we can appreciate the fact
that there is a brown m m which serves
to validate black and brown bodies
still there has not been any ad campaign
so far as i'm aware
dealing with systemic racism or police
brutality we have not seen an ad for
example where the brown eminem is
racially profiled during a traffic stop
is that because the m m's brand denies
that the black community is subject to
such persecution
or do they just not care enough to
acknowledge this reality in their ad
campaigns which is at m m's
this is all to say nothing of the fact
that still even now in the year 2022
they haven't introduced a line of m ms
where the m is written in braille for
the sake of the visually impaired
this continued oversight effectively
makes it impossible for blind people to
eat m ms a problem that could be solved
by litigation or legislation if congress
could get its act together but which is
you know a truly inclusive company would
address on its own
of course this is part of the long
history of eminem ableism
for a long time their motto was if you
remember melts in your mouth not in your
hand
completely ignoring the fact that some
americans don't have hands
so it's clear that eminem's commitment
to progress equity and inclusion is
tentative at best
disingenuous at worst
this rebrand is an improvement
it doesn't go nearly far enough
all i can say to m m's is this
list in
two marginalized communities
hear what they're saying
and do the work
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated